hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel so
there's a lot of career advice out there
a lot of career advice for software
engineers people who work in tech just
people in general and i know that i have
made a lot of videos about career advice
and stuff but today i wanted to make
something a little bit different i've
been thinking a lot about just like
working how we work how to work well
what is working mean what relationship
do i have to work because i've been
changing a lot and i realized that i
have these things in my brain still from
the days that i was a software engineer
about like the hidden secrets of like
advice and career tips and stuff that no
one really taught me but has proved
extremely useful for me in my career and
quick note before we start this is
extremely subjective these are very much
my opinions so the first hidden secret
that i want to talk about kind of
underlies everything that i do which is
around if you don't understand something
seek out why and always choose curiosity
over judgment if you seek curiosity over
judgment you're just going to learn a
lot more the world's going to become
bigger to you you're going to be able to
see things from different perspectives i
think it allows your creativity to
flourish as well and people are going to
notice like you're going to have all
these innovative ideas and thoughts and
perspectives that people are going to
seek you out for because you're open to
like learning about things and like
really diving in and like growing your
skill set and all of that just in life
you know when you seek something or you
find something that you don't know i
feel like it's always best to look at it
with curiosity than to judge it first
and i think that also comes from like a
place of humility knowing that we're
never gonna understand everything we're
never gonna know everything i definitely
really felt that like three or four
years into my career and i was like i
know what i'm doing but i also have no
idea what i'm doing and if anything i
know everything that i don't know more
and so that kind of humbled me and like
instead of being overwhelmed by that or
being kind of like oh but i know what i
like and i know what i don't like so i'm
going to judge everything that i don't
know it might as well be open to it let
the energy flow through you let the
knowledge flow through you and allow
yourself to be curious hidden secret
number two which i think is kind of like
a telltale sign of i don't want to call
it maturity but let's just say like
experience of somebody in their job and
that is to be resourceful so to me being
resourceful means like going a little
bit of the extra mile or like being
really good at finding things or
unblocking yourself to allow yourself to
do the job that you need so if you're
blocked because you need assets from a
designer like maybe go look for it
yourself and see if you can find it
yourself or just like create some like
mock design assets that you can use in
the meantime while you're waiting for
the designer to come back to you because
if you're resourceful like that if you
just help others and help yourself do
work and unblock yourself in that way
people also notice so that designer who
has those assets that you really need
might really appreciate that you went
kind of on your own way and unlocked
yourself so that you're not kind of
putting pressure on this designer to
like deliver everything because you
don't know what's going on in their life
they're probably also swamped too i just
think that if you're resourceful then
people notice mostly in the form of like
they like working with you because they
see it as you supporting them in their
role when people like you your job is
easier because then they're more likely
to work well with you and they're more
likely to return the favor as well and
be easy to work with so
be resourceful another common tip about
leading a successful career in tech is
to arrive with skills that are necessary
for the job and so that's where i want
to thank the sponsor of today's video
aws courses so amazon launched aws
courses in october of last year as a way
to help you to learn everything there is
to know about aws created by aws experts
by the way if you don't know what aws is
it's amazon web services and it's one of
the most popular cloud platforms there
are out there and a lot of different
companies use it so chances are if
you're a software engineer you're going
to come across it so if you've ever
wondered how it works how to use it and
how to use it well then aws courses has
got you covered there you can choose
from a selection of popular courses and
receive video text and quizzes as well
as various interactive knowledge checks
and downloadable materials so say that
you're in college or you've just
graduated college and you want to appeal
to a new employer then you can arrive
with these aws skills by taking these
courses by the way all of the courses on
there are free and so if you're
interested then go to amazon.com
aws courses to start learning today
thank you so much to aws courses for
sponsoring and now let's get back to the
video hidden secret number three which
who this is something that i definitely
had to learn throughout my career is to
stop asking for permission this lesson i
think was actually the hardest for me to
learn because i've only ever asked for
permission in my whole life permission
to go hang out with friends permission
to spend money permission to exist
sometimes i feel like maybe it's maybe a
very japanese kind of thing there's a
saying of like don't ask for permission
ask for forgiveness which is kind of
aggro i'm not gonna lie not a huge fan
of it but the essence of it i think is
valid and specifically i mean in things
like tech where like sometimes you
really need to gain so much support and
alignment in order to get the approval
to work on things but if you could just
like make the thing and then show to
people why it's good people are a lot
easily convinced that way that it is a
good idea and so if you are kind of
someone who is not great at gathering
support and alignment which let me tell
you that's a really hard thing then just
do the thing and then see what happens
there it's very tricky to know like how
to do things without stepping over a
line which really involves you needing
to know where that line is so like talk
to your manager about those lines what
those boundaries are who's responsible
for what what you can help out on get a
second opinion before you cross that
boundary a little bit and do things
without permission from another person
to see if it's a good idea a lot of
different ways without being like super
aggro about it the fourth hidden secret
is that communicating your limits
doesn't mean that you are weak or
unskilled so it's really hard to
communicate your limits because i feel
like in tech there's this kind of like
more is better do the most work that you
can the best work that you can push
yourself to your limit grind hustle
culture etc etc but the reality is we
all have limits we have limits on how
much work we can do how much energy we
have for that work and that's totally
okay i used to think that like by saying
that you can't do something or that like
you have a limit to something it means
that you're weak or that you're not able
to do that that's not true it just means
that you have boundaries and you have
limits and that's totally human and to
recognize it it's a lot better slash
like people like that more
than saying that you can deliver
something or saying that you can do
something and then not doing it by
communicating those boundaries people
can have the correct expectations for
you and then if you end up like over
exceeding then they're like pleasantly
surprised it's better if you can say
that you're working on them or that you
want to be better at like being able to
do the thing that you can't do but it's
okay like i feel like you're always
doing a favor to people if you can
communicate clearly what you can and
can't do hidden secret number five is
this whole concept of this i scratch
your back you scratch mine when you're
working with other people you're working
in a certain context you're doing work
together to like deliver features or
build a service or improve on an
existing one especially if you're a
software engineer the context and
pretext of all of this being that you
are employed at a company that has a
mission that they want to do or solve or
a product that they want to build and
you are working to contribute to that so
you're going to try your best in a way
that feels most authentic to you in
order to contribute to that your
co-workers are also going to try their
best hopefully in order to contribute to
that in the way that feels most
authentic to them and it's natural that
there's going to be collaboration points
where you do those things together and
then when it comes to collaboration it's
just like any other relationship i think
it has to be equal there has to be like
an equal amount of investment from both
sides in order to work and so i think
that's where this kind of whole like eye
scratch rebecca scratch of mine kind of
thing comes up in order to garner like
support favor like in order to be liked
by other people in your company
sometimes you have to do things for them
sometimes they have to do things for you
but at the end of the day it's like a it
has to be a mutual relationship because
favors do happen in companies like
say for instance that i do all of the
reviews for a pull request for a given
like co-worker but they don't review any
of my stuff even though i sent it to
them that'd be kind of unfair right and
so by me taking on someone else's pull
request i fully expect that they're also
willing and likely to review my pull
requests so long as it makes sense and
they're the right person to review it
that's not to say that you can't have
like good warm like feedback sessions
with each other if the balance gets
thrown off or like the balance always
has to be at 50 50 but i think in order
to have healthy work relationships it's
a really important thing to like be able
to
keep track of to see whether your
relationships with other people at work
are fair next hidden secret is that you
are gonna outgrow your role and that's
totally okay i don't know if this is
actually super secret because i think a
lot of people know that especially given
that people in tech change jobs every
one and a half to two years sort of
thing but it's okay like a job is not
forever and so you should know that when
you're signing on to a company you
should also know that when you're
starting feeling like
this roll in ain't it for me anymore at
a company too and so that's related to
the next hidden secret which is
sometimes the best way to get a raise or
like level up in your career is to
switch jobs it's unfortunate that this
is the case but management and
leadership at different companies are
not equal which is totally fine because
i think the industry is kind of made so
like you can thrive in certain
environments but not others with us
because there's so many different
companies and cultures and people and
teams out there and so if you're just
kind of feeling like um i feel like i've
learned everything that i could from
these people or this project or this
team or technology it's okay to move on
honestly the company's gonna exist
without you honestly the code base is
not gonna explode if you're gone if
you're a software engineer if you're a
founder it's probably gonna shake up
things and i think most companies fully
understand this that people are trying
to advocate for themselves in their
career and so if they feel like they're
not getting what they need at a company
they're going to leave and that's
totally fine the best managers and
leaders totally get that if they don't
then
i think it can be kind of a toxic
environment so you should probably
reassess that and then my last hidden
secret which is related to kind of this
whole like if you are going to leave a
company then when you're going to look
for a new company then it's to look past
the curtains of hype and courtship at
any company to see what's really going
on this actually isn't limited to just
like looking for a new job but just like
in general this okay this is gonna sound
really pessimistic but people are really
good at marketing people are really good
at hyping things up in tech and you have
to like look past that and see what's
actually going on because especially for
engineers when we are really dealt with
dealing with the details and actually
executing on stuff we are where the
rubber hits the road and so if
recruiters are painting a rosy picture
of what it's like to work there or
managers are doing that i think it's
really important to be realistic about
like okay so like yes the company
culture and the company work-life
balance is awesome but where does it
suck and can i live with that and if a
company says they're changing the world
for things then like really kind of
think about it because i it's really
easy to appeal to that side to
individual contributors like the work
that you were doing is changing the
world but realistically is it though
like is it really changing the world or
is it changing this certain aspect of
things for these individual people in
certain use cases and what's actually
happening is gonna differ like based on
who you are and what your perspectives
are on the life in the world and stuff
but that's important to do you have to
understand what your values are and like
what you're willing to live with and not
live with so for instance if you're
interviewing a company you could ask
those existing employees what are the
challenges that you and your team are
facing right now some employees might
not be comfortable talking about that
which is totally fine because employees
sometimes don't want to like talk poorly
of their employer because the employer
has the power to fire that person
there's this whole kind of power
misbalance there so yeah don't fall for
the jargon don't fall for the marketing
it's good it has a purpose there's a
place there's a reason why you were able
to find that company because you
resonated with the message that's
getting put out but if you're really
thinking about what is going to be the
day-to-day or what it's like to work
with that person or you're going to work
on a project with them
be realistic all right so those are all
the hidden secrets of leading a tech
career from me to you hopefully that was
helpful i apologize if none of that made
sense but in my mind it does if you have
any hidden secrets for others or for me
then leave them in the comments down
below again one of the inspirations for
this video is just like seeing this in
day-to-day life when even in my work and
realizing what's helped me to get to
where i am and also helping others to
get to different parts of their career
as i've been kind of giving advice to
like individuals you all people through
my ios dev academy on what it takes to
become a successful software engineer
which yes success looks different and
means different things to different
people but i think there are some core
truths that allow you to like do the
work that you want to do no matter what
that work is a lot of it honestly is
just being a fun and good and easy
person to work with because everybody
likes to work with people who are easy
to work with and so hopefully these
skills will help you by the way this
codes pusher is limited edition so you
can pre-order using the link down below
if you're watching this at the right
time make sure to subscribe to my
channel if you haven't done so already
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]